je pense qu'il faut qu'on arrive à
définir collectivement quels sont
justement le type de molécules et de
spécialité qui devrait être priorisé
avec un prix en adéquation
pendant combien de semaines ou mois je
pense que c'est un sujet qui est aussi
important et qui soit aussi finalement
on a des équation avec l'outil
industriel je pense que vous avez bien
compris que l'outil industriel ne peut
pas répondre en situation d'urgence à
toutes les situations
aussi prendre en compte la dimension
européenne l'idée c'est que les
médicaments Ayo passion et si tous les
pays stockent les médicaments on n'est
pas sûr d'arriver à la finalité puisque
l'outil industriel européen ne pourra
pas répondre à ça donc je pense qu'il y
a une histoire de d'être raisonnable et
responsable sur les stocks et c'est ce
que je me permets d'appeler du stock
qualitatif
et encore une fois on l'a pas abordé
mais je pense qu'il y a des discussions
à avoir en termes d'harmonisation
européenne et qui me paraît très
important de le dire aujourd'hui nous
souhaitons une convergence des
législations européennes donc sur cette
liste de médicaments prioritaires
critique enfin on peut l'appeler
différemment sur les stocks sur les
conditionnements aussi est-ce qu'on
souhaite du conditionnement primaire
intermédiaire on n'a pas abordé la
notice électronique mais tout ce qui
peut fluidifier en fait
on va dire cette lip circulation des
médicaments et notamment en période de
crise est importante donc gérer au
maximum à l'échelle européenne nous
paraît aussi un moyen d'anticiper
ce type de situation